hello and welcome mrs. San Luis chess
club YouTube channel and national master
Ramon Kozlov and today we have very
special lecture dedicated to the memory
of a great chess player Karl Schlachter
[Music]
right now in our studio is a December
27th evening time here in San Luis which
means in Europe is already
I think 28th and actually you can see
there is no date no day actually right
on the screen and I need to tell you
that she lecture died exactly 100 years
ago she died exactly at night 27 to 28
night somewhere in Budapest in a clinic
and so in memoriam Carl laughter let's
begin and for beginning actually I have
a little bit not really related quiz to
the personality of great chess player
you can see our YouTube viewers can you
take a look at this so named the player
and the year for position displayed on
diagram what was the move and here in
this move is white you know let's begin
with it not very simple quiz comparing
to what real master Kevin was doing to
you right now let's check what do you
know about this position first of all
raise your hand if you ever seen this
position ok so I will give you a hint
in all positions in this quiz no B
positions from world's chess title
matches and very very critical games
which changed the history of chess so
very good try it is not of course we
will pay attention to select the last
curve 19 and 10 of course this is one of
the reasons why we came here but of
course it's not actually it is little
bit earlier its 1898 so this is the
answer
Oh stainless three boring hawala 1892
day number 23 right now
stainless is winning nine to eight and
they played for 10 wins and actually if
sugaring would win this position she
guerrillas right here she has extra
night and if she Gordon would win this
game they would have tie break so that's
how she borin was close to the world
title which he never got and in this
position you can see that she go and
play Bishop before what do you think
would happen after this so think about
it
Bishop two before and after that
actually chigorin who had a long beard
almost tear up tear out this his beard
away it was very very upset
no what can we say what do you think
Bishop before is given black opportunity
to do rook to d5 you are taking pawn for
freedom not a bad try is there any
better ideas rotate Shh - Kim Ji Won and
and second rook is going to g2 and this
is checkmate
so actually we need to say that you're
going just blunder checkmate in two
moves I can just only imagine what has
happened in his mind in this moment like
in Havana in Cuba it was pretty hot
there and probably her just sitting and
just crying somewhere under the palm
tree no that's it
next game more complicated probably or
maybe less complicated first what do you
think about this position why do you
move here
well according to Grandmaster Veronica
Dan White has extra fold right that's
what I think no I have strong feeling
that black cannot win this game right so
it's either win or draw and how many
different moves do you think we have
here in this position why how many
different plants we can provide here
yeah no probably King can run and just
support this phone right what are other
options checks right King comes closer
to the pole let's say King d7
to attack your rook so and then you have
to come back right well actually I think
there are no other ideas in this
position at all so King has to come to
the pole support it to become a queen
andrew has to somehow after that
protected I would play King g3 or keen
f3 I don't see a big difference anyway
you're going to G for push and rook away
and then coming closer to pole and
pushing group
this is Anand gelfand actually 2012 in
Moscow tiebreak game 3 that was rabid
and and that moment an ant was winning
he won second game in Rapids and out of
four games and the elephant actually
could equalized the score when in this
game and here he played truch a seven
like after this game probably no one in
the world can explain what is the reason
of this mob what is the meaning of this
mode I just simply cannot understand so
Luca is 7 and then black king was just
faster if you'll take a look Lucas 7
king deceits King g3 king closer kin G 4
rupees coming then after a few more
chairs that was a draw immediately that
was last chance for Delfin to continue
the smash last game was a draw and match
was over Island State continued his
world title battles later constant came
for him well that was last chance for
Gelfand
no more chances for him anymore all this
is more complicated this is much more
complicated what do you think about this
black to move here
no first of all who is better here
number of bones is equal right white is
slightly better the white has two
bishops usually two bishops is better
than your opponent has doesn't have to
be shops and question that black can
actually win a poll right so that's
exactly what has happened in this game
so Bishop takes c1 King takes e190 xb3
check and then actually you understand
that black has double pawn so this point
doesn't have real matter that is not a
mistake by the way this is not a mistake
here you can see the answer Bishop takes
c1 it's not a mistake but after that
Bronstein was continuing to struggle
with his two knights and later he made
another mistake in lost and this is game
number 23 of the tweeny Bronstein match
1951 so two matches from the Yun
Bronstein is winning one point and
between ik equalized with his game in 24
game last game was drawn and Bronstein
never had any other chances in his
career so that's how close he was
actually one move and one game next one
I am sure you have to do that at least
our YouTube viewers should know what
this position is about this time I even
don't ask you actually what to do
because I have no idea what to do this
is this is much harder I know this is
mistake but I don't understand why I've
looked after that so computer is showing
that this position is very good for
white and you have to attack immediately
something like night C for pushing
Bishop away or doing something like this
and actually this is a physician from
Carlsen Quran and match which has
finished yeah yeah if you just one month
ago right and Carlsen karana as you
remember all games were drawn and then
they came to tiebreaker Carlsen one old
three games against Quran and this is
exactly the game where Khurana played
white and he had the only one she
actually no the only but the last chance
to win this match in game number eight
here
koala played h3 and if I would be in his
place here I would definitely play h3 I
will make exactly the same mistake
because I really don't understand what
is happening in this position but people
grandmasters are saying that h3 is too
slow and you have to attack immediately
and then you will have some achievements
now next one I have feeling yeah let's
say ten seconds and we can hear all
right black to move by the way there is
only one question here who can ask this
question
it's a complicated question by the way
what do you think black can do or maybe
cannot
that's a question yeah so black can take
on f2 or cannot that's a question so if
you take on f2 king goes probably to g2
and then is it dangerous or not
will our knight come back where he will
die there on f2 then night h4 probably
there are some checks it's a very very
nice combination that's what has
happened between Carlson and Kuryakin
game number 10
somewhere in right from the opening and
Kuryakin was winning at that moment and
there were only three games to the
engines that I can miss his chance
Knight xf2 was leading right to the draw
many exchanges they're just going right
to the draw he missed this chance he
played d5 and after that he never got it
anymore
Carlson never gave give it back to him
and to actually this game
Carson win one equal the score and after
that also correction lost untie break
and rapid chess and two more I think
right this is it
who is better why do you know oh sorry
why turn off I'm sorry this mistake
whatever
who is attacking me who is controlling
Center as many good pieces it's probably
white right so yeah actually I like the
position of Queen and Bishop on these
two squares they're thinking that queen
is doubled with rook Queen is double
with Bishop but actually everybody is
coming for a king and coming with a nice
move e5 to break everything to explode
and actually very soon in this game
black were not checkmated but lost many
many pieces
Karpov Korchnoi Baguio 97th 1978 and
it's a very last game 5-5 at this moment
and they played up to six wins and
interesting that right before this
commissioner won three games in a row
so from five to two five five but Karpov
recuperate and came for the last game
and just want it so six five that's why
we know that Karpov is a great champion
he five was the winning laufen Kirchner
actually never had any other chance had
another wish but he was completely
destroyed there two more
now here you definitely can find the
correct mode
first who is better
a number of poles is equal right what do
you think about different pieces
what about two groups which rope is
stronger why focused on what do you
think night versus Bishop who is better
night is not simply better matters come
just destroying Bishop Bishop is a logo
on a white square right and the white
square and all pawns in the light
squared usually it is very bad for
Bishop oh yeah seven yeah Knight checked
we have seven and then King can move and
something like this
yeah but Knight and Roop together cannot
checkmate they need support and
supporter is coming the supporter is
coming very very fast and that was a
great move f4 and then move pawn moved
to f5 then poor move to f6 and actually
after that black King was even checkmate
Crimea Clara 2004 that was the only one
chance for Leo to become a world
champion black was leading to one and
this is lost
actually example where champion was
losing before last game and saved it and
this was a salute lee brilliant game by
Kramnik and i think the lack of no white
one so f4 then it was a few checks and
five and polos going forward and look
night and porn together organized a big
big crucifixion to the black king and
lacquer was also very upset about it and
the last one
this position we will study today even
though that we have a special video
dedicated to this position here I to all
our YouTube viewers I need to Queen h1
and yeah that's it so here in this
position white has only two options
either Queen h1 check or Queen h4 check
I can tell you one of this move is just
making a media draw second is
immediately losing no not immediately
but losing and this is a game from our
hero last gosh laughter match in 1910
very last games nectar is winning and
you see this like a toss a coin there
are only two possible moves here one
check or another check he's winning one
nail this is very last game draw is fine
for him he made a wrong choice so this
is our hero of the day Carlos left our
great good master from Vienna actually
from Austria and I for this game
specifically I need you refer that we
have special video made by Ben
Feingold's dedicated to world champions
title medicine he has specific video
dedicated to one game actually to this
game so we'll take a look a little bit
in this position later but I want to
address you to that one alright let's
begin
so Karl selector I need to tell you that
when I came to adjust the Chess Club in
1994 and started to play there as an
active tournament tournament player
somehow it happened that selector was my
favourite chess player out of that just
my favorite chess player like you people
have favorite football players
basketball players I don't know how how
did it happen I didn't know much about
him at that time maybe I just liked his
beautiful surname
which by the way means in German just
worse it's not very nice thing when how
to leave when when you have surname
worse people are just addressing you
hello worse could be better or schlep
them yeah actually that's not my job
that's Joe Quebec and Ben Feingold and
right he was born as we mentioned in
1874 in Vienna and very good family and
they provided pretty decent education to
him he studied in kind of we will call
it trading college so after that he
started to work he was a young man like
nineteen years old man
and he started to work in like a trading
company import expert something like
this but something happened in his life
actually he met chess at that time it
was not a good idea
to work in trading or to become a chess
professional and here you can see his
match with York Marko that's right and
later he became his good friend and you
can see the result of this match that's
a brilliant match right so after this
match lector decided that probably he
can become chess professional and he
left his trading company and he started
to to become better and better before
that yeah so actually this was the kind
of qualification for the hustings
tournament 1895 and today actually I
want to set a few different questions
and try to find answer maybe together
with you
and the thing which I really want to
prove that selector was one of the most
modern chess players ever like players
who were ahead of their times he was
like a real chess profession of our
modern time not just professional of
19th century 20th beginning of a 20th
century so he reflected marco and you
can see you know I was searching a lot
online and I was looking for different
matches there are only two matches in
the history of chess probably maybe I
didn't find who ended with something
similar this is the second one you can
see a big difference right we have added
two draws in the end and so not ten
draws at 12 joules and Karlsson karana
so here you can already can imagine the
selector and Marco we're closer to
current chess professionals of beginning
of 21st century than any other of the
time because at the time people were
winning against each other and making
brilliant games and sacrifices and
something like that so here I want to
show you two games from his young times
let me set up the position probably you
will like some of them first of them is
game between actually good also Austrian
chess masters LASIK and probably that
was blitz people right now can not
believe actually 1893 actually when they
try this game they play blitz games but
it happened all right first I want to
show you the first move of this game
treacherous playing black by the way we
can swap but probably for me a Caesar
what would you play versus before if you
need it well actually you can play
whatever you want everything is not so
bad and actually Sikorsky or orangutan
open it's not really bad so interesting
that people really play it in 19th
century we just don't know sometimes it
happens before he seeks
we should beat you absolutely normal
opening right now at least black cannot
taken before I hope you understand it
what will happen if we taken before take
on g7 and probably this rook is more
available right
this happens of 96 a3 over a three c5
very good for blitz right we're trying
to plan sharp I'm trying to be
aggressive let's continue what's gonna
happen do you find actually this is the
main energy dose Sikorsky opening phone
is going to be five try to prevent night
from second trying to prevent light from
going either to c6 or aces right right
now these two squares are prohibited no
if we cannot use our night
let's go for D 5 D for you know
everything looks normal but DeForest
little bit dangerous put it in next move
is for back come on give me give me
edges will be faster taken T for another
first of all v6 is great something more
events where schlechte we are what 19
years old c4 c4 is great something else
five why not
I'm sorry this is a poem it's sweet I
know
let's go not it in a five check 93
actually I would play of course you
should see three and sacrifice this form
but then we'll have nothing really
interesting continue 19 years old we
have we're playing chess on before 40
years of genetics we don't have many
options we are just 94 of course let's
go
that's a trouble no actually you what
are options for white oh my god it's
almost lost d3 actually I don't know any
other moves any other move here for
white take it it's a trouble probably
need to take next side here Bishop c5
looks terrible right you know wait a
second White's also should have
something for it mean takes Giselle you
take me and I take you let's make a bomb
Bishop takes chapter no I have feeling
there is only one legal move here and
now it's a brilliant move like 19th
century brilliant time people were
playing romantic seriously d4 Knight can
take knowledge can it can we take a
night Queenie one chick meets right so
let me put this night back yeah no
alright if we cannot take night
if we cannot survive let's take some
that's a rope I'm sorry not every day no
penis seven right and once again we
don't have a big choice here ideas
quintic CA the more we take the better
we'll be
don't take the night sure king is like
under big trouble
yeah no bishop c1 is probably only one
choice fill the 19th century make an
excellent
how many pieces white actually has right
now in a game yeah
Queen's play sometimes in a game of
beginners you can see that one queen is
just playing versus whole bunch of
pieces of his opening it's hard to play
you're trying to really meet it now it's
right before can we get rid of this
Queen sometime
I don't like this Queen it is yeah what
queen is protecting something and go
back to c4 can do something let's offer
to take yeah
take this room go away to the corner I
don't need you know what you make it
let's take if we don't take this rook
will come to the aid that will be just a
disaster
correct no now that we also need to take
something we gave room ok we should be a
group time to take pole I think it's a
very good opportunity another such if
you'll take a look closer to the whites
King it looks like she will not survive
for a long time no that's what exactly
happened Bishop before with still
developing this for Bishop the second
time check looks correct I have feeling
that any other ideas how do we finish
know what is the dream for what I think
the dream for watch is to develop
something somebody night or B should
know somebody let me develop at least
second piece night it's a very beautiful
move here from black extremely take this
vision
if you don't let say if we don't take
addition we have to move to be one right
and then I have feeling that must be
like Queen check and Queen checkmate
it's a very facile we're not have a
choice now that's a test try the next
one
tonight at you neither - it's brilliant
it's brilliant we are offering another
night take everything I don't need
anything just go on no first of all
that's a checkmate coming in d1 right so
not a big choice if once again if we go
here is a check and checkmate in b2 so
let's go on take it
and then Queen d2 check only one legal
move Queen d1 check King goes here this
is Institute look at the final position
I think it's remarkable has some extra
pieces but they don't really help it's a
disaster but yeah of course place it was
not a very bad player but this game was
awful and I'm really hoping I will show
you something better
but still still it's amazing right we
think CT check actually in Italian town
morose tikka there is a chess festival
where they're organizing new life
performances so huge from the main
square of this town and the huge chess
board and people are acting in the chess
pieces so this game was a very first
game chosen for that festival I think
this has some reasons but this is really
beautiful
do I like [ __ ] checked her so much and
what is happening his life little bit
later so 1895 it was the greatest
tournament in hustings and for me it's
actually beat surprise the schecter was
invited there and he played pretty well
for 22 years old player and then later
but still he got 9th place and no price
and 1896 in your work you can see so
many players playing here actually five
of them are organizers nobody knows
their names I told the wrestler find
so Newberg 1896 first surprise but here
that doesn't mean that he actually got a
first prize it means that for the first
time he got a prize in his life so he
became a chess professional in 1894 and
got first money in 1896 it's quite a
complicated life when you are chosen to
become a professional and you really
think that you will leave out of your
prizes here there's a task our YouTube
viewers you can pause and take a look
closer at the faces in this picture try
to find out some lovely people
participants in this tournament but I
have only one question here what do you
think lifter and world champion master
are from this picture it's hard to say
right you probably don't see them pretty
well this is for example this is Harry
Nelson Pillsbury from the United States
he is the only one without actually he
stood this is Schneck they're wearing a
head now this is Lasker world champion
on a picture is somewhere in the side
it's pretty strange usually the legend
to sit in the middle what here is an
ex-champion staying its first world
champion she's already pretty old TCT
that's correct but what is interesting
in this photo for me I found out that
Laster and director are only two people
in this picture who are looking
somewhere else then look at the camera
at all there may be thinking about chess
at that moment that's why they're so
good all the rest
let's continue so first price you want
actually that was not a big price and
said story he won five games here was
two and both games he lost here
absolutely winning position in both of
them was very seventh we see very many
games here most only two and later
that's exactly what has happened to him
he was uncrowned king the king of
drawers too many drawers here some more
pictures of his professional life 1904
he's going up his mr. chef longer some
more people are sitting in playing chess
yeah he's coming from one tournament to
another tournament here's new on chess
club I wanted to mention that after the
tournament in Monte Carlo 1902 was
second I think in this tournament
he was never first you know he got many
second places and third places and many
more fourth places well not I said he
was never bad he was never in the bottom
of the table and right with how his
professionals lived and the time periods
when he moved back from Monte Carlo to
Vienna he was invited by Milan chess
club to visit um you know at the time
there were not so many chess masters and
for example in Italy they were not zero
so anybody who were passing by there
would come come to us of lecture
simultaneous something else and
according to you memories of people who
participated in we launched his club at
that time it was very strange how
Shrek's her exit comparing to all the
chess professionals they have ever met
before that cuz when she left have just
arrived to the Milan chess club and
there are no strong players immediately
what he first asked for yes what
the rats are having that's more or less
correct but he asked it in a little
different way he asked ready see Ricky
that's a good idea no they didn't have
radius it's by the way very interesting
question we will come back to it right
now he asked can I place a play chess
game somebody now that's a brilliant you
are coming out right from a train
station walk into the Chess Club give me
an open it I want to play so he really
liked playing it's probably the only one
way to be just professional at that time
and I have a strong opinion it's a very
set to be a chess professional if you
don't like to play chess right now you
know I have seen some chess grandmasters
who really didn't have any pleasure yeah
there's just a profession nothing more
I'm studying opening for five hours a
day in something like this but I don't
have a pleasure when I play probably
without displeasure it's quite a set
profession yeah this is it
that's that you mean one more thing to
reveal what kind of person he was
another way
so how people actually made money the
time simultaneous and our young future
master probably asked about ratings at
the time that's a good thing no one
knows how strong those players were it's
quite a strange because if you will take
a look online and try to find what kind
of ratings lost her hat
what kind of rating ilayk cup of lanka
great world team how strong they were
it's very hard to come compare because
they were playing with other players at
that time and it's not very easy to find
interesting that I found for example one
source right now one side worth of
different graphs going up going down
showing how far away
I don't believe any of those girls
either they are showing that players
were very weak or they're shown that
players were very strong for example I
founded Oscar had his top rating of 26
50 or something like that
I can't believe in this very easily but
that was another mask not a man who
asked with the world chamber and not
even an Edward Lasker from Greece
well-known here in the United States
famous chess master it was built Oh
Oscar I wouldn't say he started to check
was that it was older brother from
Alaska who almost never played in
tournaments how can you say that this
player was playing level of 2650 which
is like a reasonable Grandmaster even
now so yeah if you want to evaluate how
strong those players where this is it
you can see the simultaneous and
actually blindfolded simultaneous
elector explain with six seven strong
amateurs in a VHS box 1898 as I remember
annc she won four and drew three out of
seven in seven games like to Morgan here
American bring mass right now set up the
new brand fold record and remember how
many games he played very 16 games warm
I got six to eight
some absolutely incredible but if you
ask me can i play seven like my level
one time in my life I played three that
was very complicated and it was very
likely that one of my opponents lost in
12 news and another was 1050 notes then
it was much easier to play that here but
here you can see Vienna is Vienna
probably it's much easier to play
blindfold chess if you have a good mug
of beer right now people don't play this
week and he was also another thing
people were smoking and shrekt it was a
very very heavy smoker I was smoking
cigars and this is one of the reason why
he didn't live longer
let's continue right so she left her is
playing better and better without real
one tournament we can mention that he's
Justice King much better but he played a
few matches the ten people were playing
matches and starting from you mentioned
with Marco then he played some more
interesting all of that matches worked
well it was one of the reasons why he
got this title of king of drawers and
here you can see that Janoski who was a
very strong player i determined in 1902
Janoski actually won the biggest
tournament of the year and right after
that he played a match projector and
full big surprise for it for everyone
she gestured one is very easy and then
everybody started to realize it's
probably actor is a pretty good player
and then it started some discussions who
is the next candidate to play with
moscow and when i asked her here in the
world champion and Lasker who didn't
play any matches for eight years started
to play with different opponents to play
best Irish marshal then he played
actually with your loss all these three
matches you one very disaster just one
way actually scores were a new a nil and
83 his opponents were just absolutely
out of his league and in 1906 selector
actually won a tournament for the first
time very big tournament in West End and
that was probably one of the most
complicated and strange system in
history of chess there were four groups
and then out of that four groups in he
played like eleven different small
tournaments to come to the final it was
very funny that in one of these groups
chess master sidelski won all games but
didn't come to the final I never heard
of this system before it's interesting
we really play in small tournament we
win in all games but you are not good
enough
I will shoot you yeah so after against
tournaments 1906 and 1907 in Boston it
was a tournament in st. Petersburg and
actually Lasker already agreed that he
will play next year mush laughter you
want time to match but to st. Petersburg
tracer came very sick and that's
actually this is a picture from the
tournament it's a very fine intro it's a
very funny picture here I have a book I
used the only one book about Karma slept
in Russia there are not so many in
English as my parents hadn't read German
there's a problem I know but does the
best I could find him trying to share my
best interest in online I was searching
all over to find the correct issue a
question who is the third guy you know
if you will if you'll really search for
my name we'll try to find this is the
only one way you can find this picture
not here in this book I can present this
guy was one of the organizers of
referees of the San Pedro her church his
name is Tchaikovsky that's very nice
that we know his name because right now
it was really see if we have a person
without a head right standing next to
them woman we have no idea who was that
no it was very by the way handsome young
man so yeah she left her plate very
badly
listen futures work got place someone in
the middle but he was sick and there's
another interesting story but she
actually in this tournament actually
exactly about this game this game was in
a very first round and roster came late
he can lay for half an hour
after the very first move she left her
maid and went away to the garden and
then he was walking there for next half
an hour looking at the largest chicken
is it half an hour already enough and
after half an hour he came back and
continued to play and after the game he
said that I didn't need any help
it was a drop of course as always
perspective even from champion of the
world it was kind of inner justice he
was seeking no matter what and actually
in his career he never came late for any
single game people are kinfe sizing Oh
mascara knows what has happening to me
so last collector agreed that next year
they are playing and then you know she
is coming
I have money I'm serious that's exactly
how it happens time so he had a good
sponsor which is a friend of his
somewhere in Monte Carlo or you know he
was usually playing in all casinos do
the pocus prizes that's right before the
measure of collector of this Lasker said
ok money is good lets you know ski give
a chance and actually he gave him a
chance
it was 8 mil terrible Gammage flexor
probably was disappointed but he was a
very very polite person he never said
anything
the only thing what he said about this
actually is a quote he said I do not
support current system
for the world type title mattress little
if he was upset that's exactly one way
he buried 1907 by the way ya be
tournament here imagined Boston 1906
selected one in 1907 he didn't win the
tournament you can see the 0-1 elector
came second and here I want to tell you
one more short story about the second
round game you can see this draw between
the Irish inspector in the second round
I want to show you one position who the
main idea of the game here the selector
had a very very good position but tarish
felt sick
he had kind of maybe a heart attack or
something that inspector offered him
draw immediately it's very unusual for
current professionals position which is
absolutely dominated there's nothing
really happened it's just a final
position he had very very nothing really
decisive but it's one way so yes so the
most important question when we are
coming the final in 1910 they agreed and
started to organize and actually it was
between Vienna and Berlin their home
cities which lecture and master the
other chess club provided three thousand
kronor as a prize in two thousand two
hundred two thousand marks Cumberland
Club for master and idea was to play 30
games and the question would maybe the
most famous question here was there a
secret Clause because requirement
what were exactly the rules for this
mesh
remember we're never published so we
don't know what does it mean secret
close actually story behind a game
number ten their last game if you're I
have to show it you remember this game
so again we're actually she acts in the
future
is it a joke but he missed it and I
finally Boston there was a question why
attractor was so much aggressive and
what she was looking for both of the
players very nice game
and I think I have found it answer I was
searching for there for a very long time
in which I have a good explanation so
forth and explanation is coming from her
next match which lost her plate with
Kappa Blanc in 1911 kappa blanka asks
for when asked about the conditions for
the next match the financial conditions
for the first time and the master
answered and kappa blanka agreed to all
points in their agreement except one and
the agreement was that if somebody would
win the match one point head and
actually it was one meal 2 1 or 3 2 then
money would be split 50-50 so if you
want to win then it was a big surprise
for me how to started to study this
question closer and it's interesting to
me at that time people were playing
matches winner takes it all so Lasker
really want all money and he really was
asking for a lot of stakes for you so
that was a steak from the NHS Club
versus take from Brunei chess club and
the winner takes all
if the match is going wrong for if one
of the players will get advantage with
only one point then they split and
before the last games Dexter was winning
one point and being a chess professional
for him that was very important to me in
the final game and get to transfer money
it's the only one source stop living you
really do think that is very important
to provide actually interesting that
this version was never I didn't find it
in english-speaking internet at all it
was not taken seriously
and I have strongly believed in
something what is getting us closer to
what exactly has happened
Shrek to explain nor for the World Chess
title champion of the world he was
playing for another 1000 mark and 1,500
cross little quiz right after the match
I want to show you a few games if we
have time but after the mesh that was
another Congress of German consul
Charles small question the quiz so after
big upset actually freshly after was he
was really upsetting he was secret after
the world chance title match
next tournament he won it was one of the
best his tournaments ever so all the
best players except Alaska where there I
mean he has been knew about little quiz
who else in history has won his best
ever tournament right after his biggest
upside so the world tried to match the
player must hit and right after that he
won his best ever tournament and
probably one of the strongest strongest
tournaments in history of chess okay at
least at that time already so in 1972
Fischer has beaten Spassky and Spassky
who didn't play that match really well
right after that with all his power and
all he didn't waste and Fischer let's
say came to 1973 USSR National
Championship and won it and this was
really extremely strong tournament so
everybody played there Petrosyan
smooth Slav tau Karpov who later became
world champion that was extremely strong
tournament and best tournament ever
Spassky one actually after that he never
won anything serious
Oh coming closer so here are three other
tournaments I don't have little time
I've been probably next lecture about it
San Sebastian 1911 1912 he didn't play
really well in the tournaments and was
it became harder for him to win but
Carlsbad 1911 was fine
he started with seven wins in a row not
so bad for king of draws and here you
can see the winner in the middle very
hard take one that was best his
tournament in in his life and Viktor
kids the person the organizer of the
tournaments who invented the price
system distribution of earnest money was
distributed in the astronomist under
teat system that's also a person need to
be mentioned and that was a very big
tournament 26 players played there and
very many young players and collector
probably already realized that too many
strong young masters are coming and that
was maybe one of his last big success
successful tournaments he got second
place shared second third place with
Rubinstein what I mean by dress code
here if you'll take a look at them they
look pretty similar and pretty amazing
right now we had a very nice discussion
in facebook with Emil suit offski on his
page the new director of feeder and here
right now organized was an organization
for world's rapid and blitz championship
and there was a big discussion what does
it mean smart casual and very many
players really didn't want to go and
play if they will not be allowed to play
Indians it's very strange to me but it
looks like for many chess professionals
of our time to feel comfortable it's
more important than to be good-looking
at that time you can see that selector
was always liked in the top level but as
you may know probably on this is 1911
and other very very big chess match
tarish who was a leader of german chess
you can see the picture of him here so
exactly how people in Vienna were
thinking about tarish the teacher she
was always telling others what is right
and what is wrong and even you can see
how he and he's sitting here and she
left he really wanted to play another
match with last Kara to do it so he had
two beats laughter and he didn't do that
you can see that she never drew again no
matter what you do it is going to draw
that was a great match there's also a
few nice games there and very very soon
1914 st. Petersburg early 1914
these are finalists maybe you can call
them last girl on the left who isn't
right this one you know this is not
selected that's exactly doctor tarush
yeah and here you can see the new
generation frank marshall from the
united states
this was his good tournament and he was
still young you can see that and to
future world champions kappa blanka and
a very young awaken that's probably his
very first big big success selector was
very lucky he had very good score with
Aleichem but she was 17 years old only
as a good try and the question where she
actor actually he didn't come to st.
petersburg he was invited of course they
they organized it very very strong
tournament he was invited and relaxed
there was a chess professional and he
really felt that his power is not same
as it was a few years before so actually
right he just didn't go there he came to
the local tournament got third place
here got some money and he took care of
his old mother trying to spend more time
with her in vienna and actually that was
his last chance to participate in such a
great tournament because right after
that
that's right after that in 1914 started
World War one and that was very hard for
everybody especially austro-hungarian
Empire participated heavily in this and
you can see that somewhere close to the
end of this war
she left her plate another match with a
new growing star Rubenstein and this was
the only one match in his life he has
lost that's also great match and you can
see how old he is here how old looking
right sitting right here and this last
tournament he played in Berlin in 1918
right after that so all best were
invited there was the only one
tournament in his life where he didn't
win any single game what still wasn't
lost when she left her entourage sitting
here they had a very hard life under
World War one Tara for example lost
three sons on that word and Schlachter
came absolutely sick and malnourished
and you can see and guess how old is he
on this picture
forty-four he is 44 and he died two
months right after that tournament and
actually Lasker is six years older than
him and tarish is 10 years older it's
very hard to believe it when you look at
electorate in this picture so there was
a very hard time and during World War
one he was mostly participating in local
tournaments and to say what kind of life
it was that in one fan of chess provided
a special price for players in one of
these local tournaments he provided a
pound of butter it was a special price
for a winner even not in money so pound
of butter was pretty good price at that
moment what is really amazing I was
readin very many different quotes about
lecture and lecture never said anything
in public been published about other
people just never and no one ever said
any bad word about him any single so he
was just a perfect gentleman
and great chess master for example in
one of the tournaments another short
story right before that the young
Grigory 11 fish who came to the
tournament in Carlsbad in almost the
last round and selector had to win that
game and position was absolutely equal
and after the games 11 fish made a few
mistakes and finally lost and after the
game she left her asked him why didn't
you offer a draw 11 fish said I couldn't
this was a very important game for you
and she left her said like an absolutely
equal position I cannot refuse a job
so as live in fish said he was the only
one chess player of the time who didn't
squeeze out points from his opponents
and the 1918 exactly 100 years ago he
went from Vienna to Budapest which is
pretty close to try to make not even
some money but to find some food it was
very very hard to find it there and a
Christmas Eve he wanted to come back to
Vienna and write on the trails railway
station he was robbed see he has lost
all his goods and money and was just it
was really terrible so he came back to
the hotel and Budapest Chess Club helped
him a lot and provide it all all
possible help but he got sick and in two
days he died they put him in a hospital
but he was absolutely malnourished
he weighed like I don't know how many
that in pounds but it was like fifty
kilograms which is 14 years old go his
way yes yeah that was very very hard for
him and after that only doctors diagnose
tuberculosis and pneumonia so here all
of this in one and he never even tried
to do something with that thank you very
much I think it is hard to have a
lecture with games and biography in the
same time probably next time we'll have
more games thank you and see you next
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]